Film Courage: To anyone working
in the film industry Sujata
if they had to put a time limit on becoming
a working professional what would that be?
Sujata Day, Actor, Writer/Director: Never put a
time limit on Art I would say because have found
throughout my years there have been a lot of my
friends and acquaintances that I've been in touch
with or met in acting class or through writing
and Anyone who puts a time limit on it such as
if I don't do this thing within a year or if
I don't do this particular goal within two
or three years then I'm going to go back to XYZ
which could be anything which could be in my case
I have an engineering degree so if I were to say
that okay I need to get to direct a studio film
within five years or else I'm gonna go back to
engineering I feel like the universe hears that
and listens to that and says okay you have this
backup plan so it it would it won't give you that
first thing that you want and just think it's
a everybody says this but it's a marathon not
a Sprint and I've noticed that there are goals
that I hope to have wished to achieve by this
point which I haven't achieved but I'm enjoying
the journey and the journey has been so much fun
so it's all about waking up in the morning being
excited that you actually get to pursue your dream
and enjoying the moment that you're in whether
it's oh you get to go pitch to a certain executive
or Studio or network today or whether it's you get
to go have coffee with a certain writer that you
are inspired by and and just taking those little
experiences and making that exciting and making
that a goal as opposed to I need to sell a show
by this date or I need to be a series regular by
this date so I truly believe you can't put a time
limit on your dreams when you were getting that
engineering degree was that your plan a at the
time no that was always my plan B so I'll take
it back to my childhood where I was always dancing
singing writing acting but I was also really good
at math and science it came easy to me and when I
entered Middle School I started doing plays when I
entered High School I started doing musicals and I
was always dancing every week and my parents were
very supportive and they would come to Guys
and Dolls every night and bring a bouquet of
flowers and cheer for me and it was always really
exciting but then I was also taking AP Physics AP
Bio AP chem AP Calculus and killing it on those
exams as well so my plan my master plan I started
thinking about when I was about 16 or 17 and I
said to myself okay I can't move to Hollywood at
the age of 17. so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go get this engineering degree and take it from
there and then move out to LA after I graduate and
so I went to get my engineering degree and in the
meantime continued to do plays and musicals and
continue to write in college I took a semester of
screenwriting I took a semester of playwriting
and then I the summer before my senior year of
college I interned at a company called Accenture
which is a global consulting firm really big name
they're on par with Deloitte intuition Ernst young
and had a fun summer interning there and at the
end of that summer I was offered a full-time job
so this was even before going into my senior year
so they asked me where I wanted to work what
city I wanted to work in and I said Los Angeles
and I said Los Angeles and they said great that's
where we'll send you after you graduate so I went
into my senior year already having a job and as
soon as I graduated I moved to LA on accenture's
dime and then I was on a salary so I was making a
shitload of money at the age of 20 pretty much and
the thing about Consulting is you never have to
work unless you're placed on a project so
basically that entire year that I worked
there I was only on a project for about two weeks
and I was the worst Accenture employee you could
ever think of and I just had all my phone calls
go to my cell phone never went into work and
in the meantime what I was doing was meeting
with agents I was going to acting class I was
getting head shots I was auditioning and at
the end of that year working for Accenture I
got laid off which was also awesome because I
got Severance I got unemployment and for about
eight to ten months I believe I was just yeah
I was just like making money and that's when I
ramped up my auditioning and about I don't know
months later I booked three National commercials
in a row so that's when my professional career
started I believe and in the meantime I was
still writing scripts still writing shorts
writing short stories poems songs Etc and
that's how I got into acting but it was all part
of the master plan of like okay I don't want to
be a burden to my parents I want to be able to
support myself what's the best way I can do that
okay let's take this job in this other field which
is kind of the perfect day job to be honest and
then I moved out here and did it on my own how
did you get word that you were being laid off
what was hilarious was I was like I told you I was
a terrible employee so it was a round of layoffs
a bunch of employees were getting laid off at
the same time and I was one of them I came in
and the HR lady who I had become friends with she
was really sad and disappointed that she had to
lay me off and I was like I'm good please don't
waste your emotions on me and and it was it was
a good day foreign how many plan B's have you
had while you've been here in Los Angeles I've
had zero plan B's I I've had the day jobs which
have been really fun actually I think there was
always a dream of me even being an engineer the
dream that you see in TV and in the movies of an
aspiring actor is they're working at a restaurant
or they're working as a Hostess somewhere and
that's what I did and I had so much fun because I
was finally surrounded by creative people because
everyone working in the restaurant business in Los
Angeles generally tends to be an artist and that
is their day job so I had a blast I worked at a
diner I worked at a fancy Steakhouse and then I
realized that I really loved hostessing so I
was working the front of desk at these places
and it was really fun I was meeting all these
people working at really hot trendy spots in LA
and making friends and I never considered that a
plan B that was always just me making friends and
making my home in Los Angeles surrounded by the
people that I finally wanted to be surrounded by
yeah those can be fun jobs I know they can be
stressful though too especially if you think that
there is no time limit for them I think they're
romantic for a while but there's also a trap of
being in them too long I think that can really
weigh people down how do you handle or how did
you at that time well-meaning comments maybe from
family and friends that were like that's great we
love that you're still pursuing like you're
dancing and and acting but you're going to
need something more stable or you can't make real
money from this things like that well coming from
immense a little bit more maybe than usual and I
just handled it by I'd be like well this is the
money that I made on the commercial and so I'll
just like book another commercial and we'll see
what's what happens obviously it's not that
easy you don't just go out and book another
commercial but I was making steady progress
so so it did something that my my dad would
say was why don't you go to get a master's in
acting or it's always about more education and
and I was like well I'm taking Upright Citizens
Brigade classes and I'm taking really fun other
drama type acting classes and I'm taking sketch
writing classes and and everything I write like
I get a little bit better every script I write
is a little bit better than the one before and
so I just really had to explain to my parents like
this is what I'm doing I'm continuously studying
I'm continuously growing and I don't necessarily
need to go do a master's program somewhere so you
showed them like here's here's a residual check
or here's whatever the buyout check that I got for
this commercial and and maybe that quelled some of
their anxiety yeah I think it was more about okay
for your food are you eating healthy
are you out on the street somewhere
and and so it was mostly about just
having a stable life as opposed to
I think their version of the Hollywood dream
was more the people living on the streets and
and doing Shady things to succeed and I was
like that's in your soap operas that you watch
but that's not real life Hollywood there's just
a lot of people who are working really hard to
achieve their dreams and continuously growing in
terms of their art and that's what I want to do
what kind of heart do you think
it takes to pursue this business
a strong heart I believe as an actor you face so
much rejection pretty much on the daily and that
has made me a stronger filmmaker I believe as
a director you're continuously facing rejection
and I'm really thankful that over these past
few years I've faced so much rejection as an
actor that the rejection as a filmmaker doesn't
affect me emotionally I just say okay so you
didn't want it then I'm gonna move on to the
next person and they might say yes and I'm
going to move on to the if that person says no
I move on to the next person they might say yes
because as an actor you are continuously putting
yourself on tape you're continuously auditioning
and you may book I believe the statistic is one
out of every 70 roles that you audition for and
so I take that mindset into my filmmaking
and my writing and my directing as well
and aside from the rejection what about seeing
friends and peers at different levels around you
I mean you've had great success but I know maybe
for others or even myself or even in the beginning
maybe you see that oh wow this person is doing
really well and then you have to kind of like look
at yourself and go oh wow what how like how come
I can't emulate that I mean that's I think human
nature yeah so I think that is has personally
happened for me so when I started Awkward Black
Girl that was about 10 years ago and I was on
this journey with Issa Rae and the only thing
I took from that Journey was something positive
which was to be continuously inspired by her and
to follow the road that she has carved out for us
and I think it's really fun to watch your friends
succeed and I'm really excited we have this really
burgeoning South Asian American Community slash
Asian American community in Hollywood that we're
finally starting to come together and support
each other and support each other's projects and
definition please came out virtually through the
festivals and after that even this year I know of
three other indian-american indie films that are
shooting and I'm so excited to be able to support
them and they have all my friends in it and and
I did a cameo in one of them but it's exciting to
watch the growth and I believe 10 years ago there
was more of a competitive element to that like
there can be only one so there can be only one
South Asian American Film coming out and there can
be no others and that that thinking has changed
completely and I believe every a rising tide lifts
all its lifts all boats and it's really exciting
to watch my friends grow and make their films
and be able to put them out because I believe
Hollywood has this way of making ethnic stories
slash diverse stories very monolithic like one
point of view this is the only story that we're
going to tell about this group of people and
now we're seeing all these different kinds of
stories with within that group of people so
it's exciting to watch I think we're living in a
fun exciting time in terms of filmmakers of color
so maybe it's less so about competition anymore
because so many people are creating their own
work whereas before it was waiting to be picked
yes yeah before it was I'm just at home waiting
for my agent to call me and that's not a good
that's not a healthy place to be you it puts
you in a in a negative mental state and it's
exciting when like I said I watched Issa create
her own work put Aqua blacker on her credit cards
and succeed and make season two and get the kind
of press that she got just on her own and so I
was like I can do that if she did it I can also
do it so so it pushed me to okay I'm gonna create
my own content I'm going to put it on my credit
cards I'm gonna I'm gonna generate my own press
and so so it's really exciting because I believe
nowadays we're all helping each other and there's
a lot of positive energy and Vibes going around
what else does it take to keep at this day after
day year after year I love what I do I'm so lucky
to be doing what I do I know that I come from
a world where my friends are doctors Engineers
they work on Wall Street they are lawyers they
are business people and I am so thankful that I
have found a passion that I wake up every morning
I'm like what can I do today what kind of idea am
I going to be inspired by it's it's just really
exciting to be an artist and that's what keeps me
going just waking up in the morning and realizing
that I get to live out my dream day after day and
they're gonna be sad days when you like don't book
a job or what your script doesn't go a certain way
or where your film gets rejected by a festival but
the positive days outweigh the negative and that's
what makes it exciting and also in entertainment
your life can also change with one phone call and
I think the possibility of that keeps me going
as well have you ever had long stretches of
silence and if so how do you keep yourself
motivated or what are you doing in between
I don't really have stretches of Silence I will
say I think the pandemic made everyone slow down
and within that pandemic what I did was I put
myself through my own kind of film school I
suppose so I started watching I was taking movies
off the AFI film list that I've never seen before
I had never watched Goodfellas before I'd never
watched Midnight Cowboy I'd never watched The
Graduate all these films that people talk about
and I was so blown away by all of them I started
watching more International Cinema Akira Kurosawa
and another thing that I did was I watched a
bunch of television shows that people always talk
about I watched The Sopranos I watched the wire I
watched all of Twin Peaks I just finished watching
all of Larry Sanders and that stuff inspires me
and it's exciting to watch these amazing actors
these Amazing Stories this amazing dialogue and
even with like Twin Peaks like the crazy weird
absurdness of it all and and guess I did take
that time to just learn and be inspired by others
who have come before me and that was exciting so
that that's probably the only quiet time that I've
had but it's still very much soaking in knowledge
and it's not time where I turn off my brain I'm
I'm still learning from my quiet time so during
this quote unquote quiet time did you create
anything I did I was very productive and I wrote
two features I wrote three pilots and a couple of
different pitches had a couple different ideas but
I'm very excited about the projects that I wrote
and we've been taking them out we've been pitching
them and if if no one picks it up maybe I'll just
go do go shoot it independently again and so it's
really exciting because I feel like I really found
myself during the pandemic and found my voice and
was able to sit down at the computer and the the
words were just coming through me and onto the
page and it was it was fun it was fun and and I
did focus on comedies during the pandemic and I
think that was part of it where the world is going
through this dramatic upheaval and I didn't want
to pull that into my daily life so I was making
myself laugh every day can you talk about living
below your means and how you've adopted that
early in your career so you don't want to maybe
spend too much here or there get too confident
like this amount's always going to be coming in
have never really in my life needed like expensive
stuff and I've always been able to live below my
means I'm really good at balancing my
budget and my checkbook and even when
mean when I was working at Accenture I was making
a ton of money and so I did not spend that money
so I did not live how my co-workers lived and
my co-workers were buying BMWs and living in
these like really fancy apartments in Manhattan
Beach and not but was always aware of my plan
and I was like oh I gotta save this money because
who knows like when I do get laid off or when I do
when Accenture Finds Me Out and realizes that I'm
a terrible employee then I'm gonna need this money
to live on so just from there starting there
I knew that I needed to save and I knew that
I needed to live below my means because after that
I was doing short films for USC and UCLA that you
don't get paid for and I was doing a lot of free
acting work just to get the tape and and I was I
was living off my Accenture money for a while and
then and then I would do the waitressing jobs and
the restaurant jobs and and that would pay the
bills and like I said I would book a co-star here
and there or a commercial and and that would be
a nice chunk of money which I knew again that I
couldn't spend right away and so I I've always
been pretty good about living below my means
something that one of my friends Yvette Nicole
Brown told me that I always have on the back
of my head is if you're a guest star you should
be living like a co-star if you're recurring you
should be living like a guest star if you're
a series regular you should be living like a
recurring and so I keep I keep that in the back
of my mind and I think about that a lot and I tell
her all the time I'm like I'm always thinking
about that and she she's she gives good advice
so when you got let's say the first big acting
related check did you have a temptation to I
want to splurge this on a b and c and and did you
reward yourself or did you say no this is my this
is my winter money I need this I said this
is my winter money I need this I don't think
I've I've never splurged on anything unless
I needed it so my splurges have always been
if I have a 10 year old laptop then I need to
get a laptop because it keeps shutting down
or if I have a six-year-old phone then I'm gonna
get the new iPhone but I'm not someone who the
iPhone 13 just came out I don't need to go rush
out and get that I think I'm very happy with
small rewards when I when I book let's say like
booking a commercial I'm like okay I'm gonna go
get pizza for my favorite place or I'm gonna
go get ice cream like like food is something
that I care about a lot and the foods that I like
aren't very expensive so so that's a Splurge for
me I I'm not someone I will only go out and buy a
car if my car is on its last legs and undrivable
so I guess I'm like really good with money in
that sense and I had a there's I love to travel
but I have traveled a lot throughout my
childhood and even up through college so
even when I moved to LA I was like oh I don't
need to go to Europe because I've already been
to Europe or I don't need to go spend my money
in Asia because I've been to Asia so so would
always keep that in mind and I'd be like well
actually need to get new headshots as opposed to
do something splurgy and crazy so so that
something that you can reinvest back into whether
it's your acting career or a film is something
you'll put money into but it sounds like always
always will be I'll be putting money back into my
career right but not you don't need a new model
of whatever car no no and I love I love Groupon I
love living social I'm always looking for a deal
where are some of the best places that an actor or
creative can invest in themselves what can they do
I believe the best thing that you can invest in
is your work so for example I did a short film
in 2016 called cowboy and Indian and this is
how it came about basically I was doing my
taxes and I noticed that there were these stocks
that I had never noticed before and I called
the number that was that was on the tax
information sheet and I asked oh what are
these stocks and they said oh these were gifted to
you when you left Accenture and I said excuse me
okay how much are they worth and they said fifty
five hundred dollars and I said send me the check
and they say well we don't recommend you cashing
out and I was like send me the check and I got a
check for fifty five hundred dollars that I put
directly into funding my short film cowboy and
Indian which I wrote produced directed and star in
and it was a really freeing experience because I
gave myself the permission to fail on making that
short because I knew it was my first short film
it would probably turn out to be a piece of
[__] but guess what nobody was going to be
blamed except for me because I was putting my
own money into it that I didn't even know I had
so it wasn't money that I needed to make back
I was just like this was free money out there
that was mine and I had just discovered it so I
had already written the short film and it was a
five page script and I put my crew together put
my cast together and we went out to the desert to
Joshua Tree to shoot it it was a one day one night
shoot and came back went into post-production and
when I when it was finished I said oh this isn't
bad I was like this is not a bad first short film
and I started submitting it to film festivals and
got didn't get into any of the biggies didn't get
into Sundance Tiff Tribeca or South by but I got
into a lot of Asian American film festivals and
Indian American film festivals and so I did the
festival circuit I traveled with it I believe it
got into over 15 film festivals in 2017 2018
and it was just really fun and it was amazing
watching it on the big screen along with four or
five other short films that were in the same block
as mine and I have never regretted putting that
stock money into my short film was that part of
like a 401k that they it wasn't part of a 401k
it was just it was just stocks it was it was
stuff that you could actually cash out and get
the the price of whatever it was at that time
how did you meet Issa Rae so I'm at
Issa Rae on Twitter this was like 10
plus a couple months year ago 10
years plus a couple months ago and
I had just left Facebook because I just thought
Facebook was so dramatic and there was just too
much going on with having your elementary school
friends on there with your middle school friends
with your high school friends with your college
friends with your family I was like I need to like
not be part of this chatter so I left Facebook
before it was even cool to leave Facebook and
as I left it I said to myself I was panicking
a little bit and I said well I need some kind
of social media What's it gonna be and then I saw
that Twitter was happening and not happening like
today but it was it was a newish platform
so I was like okay I'm gonna make a Twitter
and then I got on Twitter and I started following
this this person Joshua at film TV diversity and
he would tweet out different writers and producers
and directors and creators to follow so I would
just click follow on every single one of them
because I didn't know what I was doing on Twitter
and and there was always really great advice
coming from Twitter from the people I follow
in terms of filmmaking and then she had tweeted
out follow Issa Rae she makes web series and I
said great followed her she followed me right back
and then a couple days later she tweeted out I'm
looking for a mixed looking girl to play my best
friend in my next web series and I dm'd her and
I said hey I'm not mixed but this is what I look
like here's a picture of me can I audition anyway
and she said yeah of course come on down and she
gave me the address and I pull up to the how this
is a house in a nice neighborhood but regardless
a house and for any actors watching out there I
don't recommend you go to a house for an audition
that's super Shady you want to drive away I did
not drive away was about to drive away but then
I saw Issa come out and she was talking on her
cell phone and I was like oh it's fine it's a girl
it's a woman still not the right attitude to have
so I went into the house did the audition it was
super chill I was there for about five minutes
and then I left and then a couple hours later she
said you booked the roll and I said okay cool and
then a couple weeks later I went to Issa's Dad's
doctor's office in Inglewood which where we would
be shooting Awkward Black Girl and we just shot a
very quick 20-minute hallway scene that I believe
is in episode three of Awkward Black Girl where
my character is introduced and it was just me
Issa and her brother and her brother was running
the camera and the sound was definitely attached
to the microphone was attached to the camera so
there was no separate sound system we had to come
hair and makeup ready and like I said it took 20
minutes and then she Isa said thank you so much
and then I left and I asked myself what did I get
myself into what is this web series like nobody to
do a web series was at the time and that's how
I met Issa Rae that's a great story you'd been
acting what eight years prior to doing Awkward
Black Girl well I've I would say I've been acting
since I was like five or six just from back
home just putting on my own shows putting
on my own performances and then doing plays
in elementary middle school and then doing
musicals and being in the chorus in middle school
and high school and so I've been acting I would
say pretty much my whole life yeah you did the
web series for free correct yes I did and that's
an interesting decision I think at the time
I was doing a lot of stuff for free so like
I said I was auditioning for AFI films I was
auditioning for USC films and UCLA films and
most of the time those films didn't even get
finished and and that was the tragedy of it
all because I didn't mind doing working for free
because it was always really fun but I believe
that a lot of the time the filmmakers came up
against wanting their project to be perfect
and then going through the post-production per
process and realizing that it wasn't what they
had envisioned and then completely throwing it out
and I believe that is the wrong attitude to have
as a filmmaker as a Creator I truly believe that
you should finish stuff and also put it out there
and also submit it to festivals and even if it's
not what you thought it was going to be it could
still be accepted as something else and so that's
the exciting part of it even if you have something
that may not have the best production quality or
the best acting or the best sound just put it out
there and guess what you're gonna learn from that
mistake and you're not going to make that mistake
again in your next thing or project will be 10
times better oh and then you just keep working
you just got to keep making stuff and putting it
out and then make the next thing so something that
I like to point out is if you watch the first two
or so episodes of Awkward Black Girl on YouTube
the production quality isn't great the sound
isn't great but there's something there there's
something there that makes you keep coming back
and then you notice as those season one episodes
go on oh I think they got lighting I think
they might have gotten microphone they might
have gone a sound person oh they're they're a
wardrobe looks a little bit better so I love
Awkward Black Girl and that it is on YouTube and
you can watch the progression of how it just keeps
getting better and better and and I think that was
when I was doing free projects I was just excited
to be meeting people and working with new people
and once again just be surrounded by creativity
what do you think made that show so popular what
made an Awkward Black Girl popular was that it
reached an audience that was being ignored by
Hollywood and it was black women that were not
used to seeing themselves on screen and that's
that's what was really exciting about being a part
of that journey and watching as the episodes came
out one by one watching the The View count keep
growing and it turned into a snowball and and we
were getting comments we were getting DMS we were
getting messages from people oh my god I've never
seen myself on screen before this is me are do you
have a camera in my home are you watching my life
are you watching my relationships are you watching
my friendships and that was the most exciting
part of it because like I said Hollywood has a way
of taking a group of people and making the same
story about them over and over and over again and
and this was such a specific story from a specific
point of view that had never been told before that
had never been on screen and that was that was
part of why it became the success that it became
season one episode seven after we
ended That season we did a Kickstarter
and we were looking for thirty thousand dollars to
make the last I believe four or five episodes and
we didn't know how much money we were gonna raise
and even the not I remember we were having we were
all kind of hanging out talking about oh how much
should we ask for should we ask for ten thousand
should we asked for 12 15 and they decided on
30 and we ended up making fifty four thousand
dollars and once again that was proof that there
were people out there that needed to see this
that wanted to see this and wanted to see how the
season was going to end what was going to happen
with white J and J and what was going to happen
with Jay at work and with her friends and so
that's what was really fun and exciting to see
that oh there is the possibility of creating
something that appeals to a certain group
of people that have never seen themselves
on screen before so that's what makes
me so excited about creating my work
sure and you think too because the
characters were it just wasn't about
stereotype it was about these are real people
not okay this person fits this stereotype or
demographic for this one role we need this like
character relief kind of thing yeah I think it
was successful because each character was a
well-rounded individual and a lot of the time
the the audience when they would message us
they would like oh my best friend is exactly
like that or the guy that I'm dating is exactly
like that so so we were tapping into something
real and and non-stereotypical for sure what
did Issa Rae teach you about the business once
you learn just by watching her Issa Rae just
taught me to be true to my point of view and
get it out there no matter what no matter how many
rejections you get no matter how many no's you get
every person has a unique story to tell and each
story is important and generally not out there
yet and there are audiences today that are not
being served by what Hollywood is offering so
I'm just excited to fill that void of content
how did you end up on Felicia Day as the guild
after that oh I don't get asked about the
guild too much so this is exciting Okay so
I believe it was season two of Awkward Black
Girl, The Guild was also I believe one of the
only other web series that had been happening
at the same time so we were aware of the guild
The Awkward Black Girl Scott Squad was aware
of the guild and and believe it was just an
audition so I had gotten an email through my reps
oh Felicia day's web series they're casting for
certain roles in their Sixth and last season and
would you be down to audition and I had known of
Felicia Day I had not been watching The Guild but
but I kind of cross-coursed it when I went in for
the audition and and it was really cool because
as soon as I walked in it felt like oh we're
we're like the two web series that are happening
right now this is really exciting and they're
both created by women which was also an exciting
thing and so I went in and I auditioned it was
really fun and I also booked that job and that
was awesome to do I believe it was happening at
the same time when we were shooting Awkward Black
Girl season two so I was working on both of them
at the same time and just had a blast and Felicia
is great and it was it was it was really awesome
to watch because they they were in their sixth
season so to watch to go from one web series to
another that was so much ahead like like the there
were extras and there were big sets and and it was
it was fun it was fun to be a part of that and to
see where a web series could go if it went on for
a couple more seasons I'm curious why you didn't
do definition please as a web series did you feel
like it was better served as a feature or or would
you want to continue it on through many seasons
because you could go many places with things
yeah yeah definition please to me was always
a feature and I'm not quite sure why I decided
on that I have projects that are specifically
TV projects that are specifically film and
and for definition please didn't even really
think of the idea until about 2015 when I was
in my UCB sketch writing class and I wrote a
four-page sketch about spelling bee winners which
served as the basic premise for definition please
and then I had started going to Sundance in
2017 and that really inspired me to create a
film to be honest and and this was also post
cowboy and Indian where I had made a short
film and once again it was really fun taking it
around to film festivals so for me definition
please was never a web series and it was always a
feature film you think it could be at some point
I think my journey with definition pleases over
okay all right I want to see like a high school
reunions different things right right different
dramas yeah yeah I think I think there is a world
that I created that could it could keep going
and people want to know what happens after Monica
moves to Cleveland but truly believe that once
I'm done with the story I'm pretty much finished
with the story and and and I have 10 or so other
projects that I'd love to get off the ground and
shoot so I'm excited to move on to the next thing
were you protective of Monica as a character how
they they write like have horrible things happen
to your character I realize you weren't making
that exact kind of film even though there were
family dramas but was it hard to let Monica go
no no have a way of detaching from my
stories and characters and so I want them to
be real and be grounded and pursue the
path that their character would take and
and I don't take it personally as a writer or
a filmmaker and so I'm always excited I think
with Monica I love that she is unlikable
in the beginning of the film and and you
are kind of trying to figure out why she's so
mean to her brother who seems really nice and
and and I love writing flawed characters as
well so so it was it was just fun to write a
character that had all these different things
going on and wasn't fully good or fully bad
what would you say those two web series did for
your career The Guild and the Awkward Black Girl
they just put me on the map I believe in terms
of exposure even at that time I had just done
season two of Awkward Black Girl I had just done
season six of the guild and then I got a call from
my commercial agent at this point I did not have
a theatrical agent and they said hey the casting
director arrested development is coming back and
the casting director wants to offer you a small
role and I said what how did they even know about
me I'm not auditioning for TV shows or films right
now and they said they had been watching web
series and they just discovered me so that was
getting to do an episode of Arrested Development
was really really special and and being on a
proper television set with hair and makeup and
craft services and them picking up my outfit and
being on set with David Cross and Alia shocket
that was just an experience that I will never
forget because I wasn't expecting it at the time
would you say you're here now because of those
two series like has your life sort of your career
the trajectory of it because of those series the
timing was right that it just brought other great
things into your life other roles oh yeah I credit
Awkward Black Girl with pretty much my entire
career and and the path that I personally chose
to take which is creating my own content and
putting my own stuff out there and taking risks
and not sitting by the phone waiting for it to
ring waiting for my agent to call me almost with
those calls when they do come are like presents
because I'm continuing to make my own content and
then when my agent does call with something I'm
like oh that's cool that's surprising and exciting
so so I love that about my life and definitely
I credit everything too Awkward Black Girl he
talked about risk earlier waiting by the phone and
now that you can take chances in a risk to create
your own work but even from a young age it sounds
like with the spelling bees for however long that
lasted that's a risk that was definitely a risk
especially at that time I was a shy introverted
kid so to get up in front of an audience I
remember that moment because when when you're
in a class of eight and you're just doing the
spelling bee there's no audience it's just like
you get your word right or wrong and if you get
it wrong you just sit and you become the audience
and I was around my friends so I do remember going
to the Regionals and seeing that huge audience and
that probably scared me off as well so what I'm
just making excuses for spelling the word radish
but anyway so it I because I see you as that
you have a lot of you wouldn't be fearful of
of challenges but it seems like you yeah I'm not
fearful of challenges now I will say like I said
I was a shy introverted kid and then in seventh
grade when I switched to public school and had all
these friends I looked in the mirror and I said to
myself I cannot be shy and introverted anymore and
then I just switched and then I was getting kicked
out of math class because I was talking too much
there was a discussion on Twitter a few
weeks back about the film Community the
writing community and the wrong way
and the right way to do something
and I just wondered what your thoughts are on that
like is there a wrong way to make a movie is there
a right way you talked about over the course of
the pandemic you made watching movies sort of
your film school but there is a dogma of this
is the right way to do something the right way
to enter a scene to end a scene do you feel that
or everyone should have their own unique Style
I don't feel like there's a right or a wrong way
I think there are greats that have come before
us that we can learn a lot from and they all have
their own Styles and if you're watching something
like David Lynch and Twin Peaks you notice that
he he tends to break the rules and and go into
melodrama which was like the best part about Twin
Peaks I just I just loved it so much but then you
then you watch something like Good Fellas and
that feels like what a film buff would say is
the right way to make a movie but but I think
just love all kinds of movies and especially
if you watch International films if you watch
something that I'm really inspired by is Sethi
G3 who is a Bengali filmmaker I'm also Bengali and
he won an honorary Oscar in the 80s or the 90s and
he what he did was he kind of broke off well he
didn't want to make Bollywood type movies which
is what Indian India was known for at the time
and he just went into the villages and started
focusing on women in The Villages and and
he would write these amazing stories about
just regular women and what they were going
through and and it wasn't about being rich and
it wasn't about Musical dance numbers and and
it was just like a quiet story and so what I
believe is there's not a right or wrong way to do
or create art and I think what's exciting to me is
when you do get out of those boxes and and we
were talking about risk when you take a risk
and and maybe it doesn't pan out the way that
you wanted to in this project then you don't do
it again in the next one you take a different
kind of risk and I love when projects surprise
me I love it when they go a certain way or do a
certain thing that I'm not expecting and that's
what's exciting to me about art which movies and
TV shows fall into as well has anyone said that
to you like this should be more this if you if you
do it more this way it'll have more marketability
I believe that happens more in the screenwriting
process and not really in the filmmaking process
get notes from my scripts and my pitches and
honestly most of the time the notes are make
the project better so it allows me to think
about the project in a different way that I
may not have seen before and and that's
what's really exciting sometimes what
happens is you'll go through like a circle of
notes taking you back to that same place where
you started but now you're more clear
about why you started with that story
so it's I appreciate notes I love getting
very hard critical notes on my work and
and I won't necessarily take 100 of the notes but
each note allows me to think about the scene or my
characters or the work in a different way so I'm
like okay where is this now coming from what is
the person not attaching onto what what are they
not getting in this part and that's where the
actual note is coming from so getting notes to me
is very very awesome because generally every time
I've gotten notes and I've done the rewrite it's
a better script than what I had written before
did anybody give you notes with definition please
like can you make it go more in this direction
and then we'll have more marketability for it
because it's really just a story about coming
being a young person whether you want to leave
the nests or stay in your small town it doesn't
have to be Bollywood it was just an experience
that happened to be different cultures that
all came together and knew each other from high
school yeah I got the I got one note that I got
I believe it was during the script process
was someone needs to die like it needs to be
in this climax moment like one of the family
members needs to die and I was like I don't think
so I don't think that needs to happen I'm really
just trying to make it a slice of life and this
could be any family it just happens to be a South
Asian American family in the center of it all and
that's what was exciting to me just to show Indian
Americans as normal people just like everyone else
I think mostly when I when I soft pitched it
around to production companies that I already had
relationships with they all said that it was too
small of a film for them to take on without really
giving me any notes in terms of like oh if you
made it like this maybe we could we could shoot it
but I understood that pass or that that rejection
per se because because it is a small film and it's
about there's no explosions and there's no big
special effects or anything so it's not one of
the five Studio films that that a big Studio would
make but wanted to make this for myself just to
just to get a story out there that I had never
seen before on screen do you see that ever though
in the film industry or right with with film and
TV writing screenwriting that there's there's
definite like this is the wrong way this is the
right way I think there is definitely a formula
to telling big budget films so if you're writing
a big budget film for a studio then there is
absolutely a correct way to do that and I don't
know if you guys have read Thomas Lennon's book
called how to write movies and make profit how
to make movies how to make movies for fun and
for Fun and Profit and fun is crossed out and
one of the first one of the first things that
he says in the book is if you're making a movie
for Sundance you need to put this book down
and gives really explicit instructions on how to
write and create a studio film and I just love the
book because I have applied it to my indie films
that aren't necessarily Studio films but but it's
also a really easy read and it's funny and it's
fun to get through and it's awesome to hear his
experiences and stories as a studio screenwriter
as opposed to me who's who's writing for indie
films but but yes I do believe that there is a
correct way to write a studio film with certain
beats and certain explosions in certain moments
that happen between the stars of the film that you
have to have in there or also Stars won't to the
film how have you found your voice as an artist
I've just written stories that I want to write
I've never tried to write something that I don't
want to write and and I'll explain that in a
way that I've I've been pitched certain books
or IP and and at first it'll be exciting but then
I'm like I'm not I don't care about this I don't
care about this subject I don't care about this
world so then I don't do it so I don't do anything
that I don't want to do and most of the time I'm
excited about my original stories and and I'll get
an idea whether I'm inspired by a moment in my
life or I'm inspired by a song or I'm inspired
by a hike that I went on those are the things that
excite me and and keep me going from from the seat
of the idea to writing the outline to writing the
entire script if I'm not excited about that seed
of the idea then I can't keep moving forward in
order to finish that script which is what I always
want to do like I said I always want to have a
finished product I have a ton of friends who start
scripts and then never finish them or like I said
they start short films and never finish them but
I think the most important thing to do especially
with the first draft of writing a script is just
finishing it the first draft is what I always
call vomit draft and it's never any good but
guess what it's 90 pages long great I've reached
my goal of 90 Pages now the hard work is rewrite
the first draft so then I rewrite it and
and I get it to a place where I think it's
okay to be seen by the four or five people that I
trust to give me good critical notes on my scripts
and then and then I get those notes and then I
continue to rewrite continue to rewrite but for
me it's always about getting that page count to
90 Pages especially with the first draft and then
proceeding with the rewrites from there that's
interesting you think the math science part of
your brain has really trained you to make sure
that you finish things that that there's a that
it all works out yeah yeah I really do and it's so
strange because because that didn't click until a
few years ago where where I'm really structured
about writing scripts and I'm like okay I'm
gonna write 10 pages this week and then 10 pages
next week and I write it down on my planner and
I cross it off once I'm done and I get to 20 40
60 80. and and and that really excites me and so
remember one thing from all of my engineering
years I walked into my first class in college
and the teacher wrote out engineer equals Problem
Solver and I said huh I said I am a problem solver
and and I use that in all of my work I use that
in my screenwriting I'm like okay well how do I
get this character out of this situation okay
how do I how do I finish the script how do I
what's if I've already written the end how do I
get there what are these middle scenes in between
even with being on set of definition please
I kept thinking about engineering equals
Problem Solver and I was like okay we've lost
this location how am I gonna problem solve
getting a location without freaking out my cast
and crew in the meantime and so I do believe uh
my training as an engineer and in math and science
has truly helped my artwork because even in
I mentioned that I also write poems and I write
songs and I had written poems and then I got
together with my friend will Collier who composes
our music and he taught me the basic structure
of a song and I could take that structure and I'm
like oh great I can definitely follow this formula
to write this song So once again that was my math
mind writing and artistic song I love that if you
were to be the teacher at a screenwriting course
or filmmaking and you wrote screenwriter equals
we actually have a chalkboard here but
screenwriting equals and what would be
the other word on the end of the equal
sign I'm gonna say Problem Solver okay
screenwriter equals problems okay because you're
always solving problems you're you're coming up
with the premise and you're always putting
your characters into problematic situations
that they have to get out of and only you can
take them out of those situations and and that's
part of what's exciting you let the characters
guide you into their own stories and and you
are now solving their problems
okay and then actor equals
Entertainer okay and last but not least
filmmaker equals visionary I like it how
do what you're creating is coming from your
unique voice what I'm excited about it so
something that was really fun for me on
definition please is that when we started shooting
I the day before we started day one of shooting
it felt like the way you feel before the first day
of school and I was really excited and I couldn't
really get to sleep but I knew that I had to sleep
and that's when that's when you're doing
what you're supposed to be doing and you're
telling a story that's unique to you and your
point of view when you're in that moment and
he just can't wait to wake up in the morning
and and get to work and tell the story that
you've been living with for a few years and
that that's what's exciting to me when I can
be excited about rewriting a script that that
I had poured my unique voice into and and and
be able to change that or adjust it and make it
a better story and and I just get excited like
I said during the during the pandemic when I was
pushing out all these scripts it was just a joy
to sit at my laptop and get back into these lives
of the characters that I had created and in each
one of those characters had their own unique
voice which wasn't necessarily mine so it was
exciting to take on those roles as well you say
you don't take something on unless it excites you
so you already know once you've taken something
on that you're committed to it you're not going to
because some people might be persuaded oh yeah all
right I'll do it I'll do it but it sounds like you
already know you have a real definition inside of
you that this is something I'm going to stick with
I have no problem saying no to things so I have
walked away from a lot of big projects and ideas
that may have made me a lot of money but that I
wasn't necessarily excited about so that that's
number one I listen to my voice I listen to how I
feel when I'm reading something or being pitched
something and so suppose I have the Marie condo
philosophy of oh is this going to bring me joy
and generally if it's my original idea yes
and then I continue on with that but if it's
someone else's idea then I really have to think
about it and say okay is this going to bring me
joy or am I going to get stressed out and and
I'm not someone who gets stressed out ever so
so those are my two questions that I ask myself
in terms of taking on a role or taking on someone
else's work in terms of writing or directing it
so have you ever rethought something that you
turned down and thought no oh no you were very
clear on it yeah very clear very clear on it
don't regret anything in my life and a lot of
people would say oh well don't you regret going
to engineering school instead of going to acting
school or and getting an Arts education and and
like you mentioned I use my engineering
and my math and science background to
create my scripts to create my stories and they
have gone hand in hand which is really exciting
so I've I've never regretted anything
any decisions that I've made in the past
compels you to write different things
different ideas I'm always inspired by
experiences so I think it's really important for
writers to go out and experience life and not just
be sitting in their room all day and writing so
something that I really loved from my upright
citizen Brigade improv and sketch classes one of
the assignments that a teacher had given us was
go out and do something new this week something
that you wouldn't necessarily do try something
new so I think during that class ate insects for
the first time which I didn't really love think
I watched like an old action movie I'm not really
into action movie so I just kind of watched that
and and it was great because you have to expand
your mind you have to learn about different things
and and those things will inspire you so whether
it's a character who's really into action movies
whether it's it's a scene at a restaurant where
they're only serving insects whether it's so I
those different experiences will inspire something
and strike a match in your brain for maybe not a
project that you're currently working on but maybe
something in the future and so so I continue to do
that even after taking the class I continue to
read something that I wouldn't normally read or
or try a new food that I that I wouldn't normally
try and that's that's what's exciting to me just
new experiences I believe inspire me all the time
how do you create a meaningful story I think as
long as you're telling the story from your heart
then other people will gravitate towards it so
I wanted to tell a story about a specific type of
family that went through Universal problems and
and I wasn't sure what an audience was gonna
think about it and and I really made it for
myself and I made it for my friends and family
because I knew that they would enjoy it and
then all of a sudden different audiences were
pulled towards it and really enjoying the film
and that was that was kind of a surprise to
me but but it's exciting to to find out that
your story that you put a lot of heart into is
also emotionally affecting other people as well
did people come up to you after screenings
I mean we didn't have a lot of screenings
because of coviduals so so it was more through
tweeting at me or direct messaging me or through
emails where I was learning that these these
people these audience members who had watched
the movie really enjoyed it and really felt
connected to it and felt something they felt seen
you talked about making sure you only do
projects that you feel compelled to do that
you don't want to do something you don't want
to go to something you don't want to be yet
what's your thought on creating a story that's
emotional versus one that's more commercial
I like them both I'm trying to create both
stories I think it's possible to create
a commercial story with emotion and heart
and I think that's that's the beauty of
making a big budget film and you can sneak heart
in there but but show it to a wider audience and
that's exciting to me I think love comedy so
I'm gonna stick to comedic stories but even
within that comedy I believe there's gotta
be heart no matter what budget you're making
the project for and yeah I have ideas that
are very commercial and I'm looking at it
for my own specific unique point of view and
and I haven't seen necessarily those stories
commercially out there yet so it's exciting to
also create for a bigger budget so you don't
think there's commercial stories that have some
type of a meaning maybe just a few out there I
think there are definitely commercial stories that
have that have heart and meaning and I think even
more so today since studios are only making five
or six movies a year they have to find a way to
make sure that these audiences coming in relate
to these characters on a certain level and and are
rooting for them and so that I mean for example I
just watched a film and I don't know if you would
call it big budget but Barb and star go to Vista
Del Mar and I thought it was so funny so absurdly
comedic but there is a story there about female
friendships and and and I just love that and it
it is a bigger budget film with with stars and
and so that that's the kind of work that I'd love
to make at some point sure was that an a24 movie
that was a Lions game oh okay all right I thought
I've seen trailers for it and looked cute I was
like okay I would watch it it's great I loved it
how did you learn to write screenplays I took
a semester of playwriting in college and also a
semester of screenwriting so in our screen writing
class we had a book called The screenwriters Bible
which taught us the the structure and the
technical aspects of screenwriting and we
we're supposed to have a finished script coming
out of that class which I did not believe my
script was about 50 pages long and and actually
went back recently to go look at that script to
see if there was something I could Salvage out
of that story and it was just terrible it was
so bad and and and I thought that was really funny
because I'm like oh that just means I've grown so
much since that first script that I never finished
and and now my scripts are like I said each script
that I write is is better than the last one
and that was that's what's exciting is to see
the progression of writing from class my first
class to to my writing now why was it terrible
it is the story just was didn't really make
any sense I guess and the characters didn't
have specific point of views and they were just in
these scenarios and scenes with no Rhyme or Reason
it was just really bad all across everything
so they were just sort of like situations and
yeah conflict yeah yeah and like I said I never
finished it it was about 45 to 50 pages and and
I don't even think when I looked back on it I
think I read the first two or three pages and I
was like oh I don't I don't need to finish reading
this shitty script that I wrote back in the day
so stage plays also you said you learned to
write why why not focus on that as well well
what is it about the screen so something
about stage plays because even when I was
asked by Accenture where do you want to live
obviously I had a couple different cities in
mine it was Los Angeles New York and Chicago
and I really decided that I was going to forego
the New York City theater scene because I didn't
feel like I ever saw people of color in Broadway
plays and so it just didn't feel like the right
place for me and that I wouldn't get any work
and so but I was always seeing people of color
in commercials and stuff so that's what made me
move to Los Angeles and that was the same kind
of thinking in terms of going into playwriting
or screenwriting I did not see plays that were
written by or for people of color to be honest
or enough of them but I had like I said I had
watched Sethi G3 films and I had seen and I
knew Bollywood was a big thing in our culture and
so I was inspired by the films and the TV that I
watched and it felt more attainable to me why is
it so important to write a perfect first draft
it's not important to write a perfect first
draft I like I said I always write a thumb
at first draft and it's actually terrible and
writing is all about rewriting so for me I'm
just trying to get to the page count and once
I get to 90 I get really excited and that is
cause for celebration and then I go back and I
look at my draft and it's terrible and so I look
through it and I do my own version of a second and
third drafts of that and then that's when I get to
send it off to my four or five friends that I
trust to give me critical smart notes that will
actually help move the script along and then I
gather those notes and I read through them and
and I see if any of the notes are actually
similar and I tackle those notes first and
then at this point I'm at the fourth fifth
draft of the script and it's getting there
but it's not perfect and then tend to finish a
script when it's on at sixth or seventh draft
that many okay do you outline I do outline so
going back to Thomas Lennon's book how to write
Movies for Fun and Profit he has this really great
chapter of outlining where his outlines are like
20 pages long so if you do a very specific long
outline where exactly what the scenes are going
to be and who the characters are in each scene you
can transfer that into final draft and then have
just the scenes in there but then you are writing
the characters and the dialogue so when you
transfer it over to final draft it's already like
15 20 pages in and so it's way easier to write and
finish a script if you have an amazing outline
and exactly where it's going to go and then you
can even hop back and forth so what's exciting
to me is like I said don't write and unless
I'm getting Joy from the script and so maybe I
want to write the ending first so then I write
the ending because I already know what scenes are
necessary to get to the end so then I just write
that ending and then I work backwards so your
writing process sounds like it it varies it's not
like you start a script the exact same way every
time it varies with each project and sometimes
I'll just get an idea and I'll start writing and
I'll be like Oh I'm writing where's this gonna go
maybe it goes nowhere but maybe it does
go somewhere and so every project that I
write it's it's a different process in terms of
getting it down on the page even with cowboy and
Indian when I wrote cowboy and Indian I saw
it more visually than with a lot of dialogue
so I just wrote the visions of the scenes
down and then it it was birthed out of that
so going back to the Twitter thread from a few
months ago that I saw about the right way and
the wrong way to do something and sort of the film
community and their opinions on it it sounds like
you just have different styles for each script
that you work on and it all ends up working out
it just there's no real process that you follow
every time for each one there's no real process
that I follow and and I think that that's what
keeps it fresh in my mind and that's what keeps
me coming back to screenwriting with my every
story every idea that I have there's a new way to
approach it and whether it's Thomas Lennon's way
of approaching something which really connected
to or whether it's just writing down certain ideas
or visions or what's a cinematography is going to
be and that's that's a whole different
way of looking at approaching a script
with engineering classes did they teach you the
same different ways to approach problem solving
so it won't be a b and c every time for the
same problem yes so something that I went
through after as I was getting my degree was I
was interviewing for a lot of different jobs and
even though I had the Accenture jobs I would go
to these interviews to be like oh maybe they're
gonna offer me more money who knows and so I
was in an interview for McKinsey Consulting
which is one of the big fancy Consulting groups
that a lot of Ivy League graduates work for and
they ask the same type of questions in
these interviews which are big ques big
macro questions that don't necessarily have a
correct answer but they want to see your brain
process of how you would get to that answer so
one of the questions that I remember getting in
this McKinsey Consulting interview was how many
French fries does McDonald's make every year
so how would you go about answering that question
and there's different ways to go about it there's
you could start with okay what does a McDonald's
sign say serving this many million people every
year you could start from there and work backwards
towards okay how many how many french fries are in
one pack how many how many people come through
there per day and how many cities are there in
the United States how many McDonald's are there
in America so you you go through this process
and you have to say the process out loud to the
interviewer so they can understand your brain
thinking skills and then you get to a number at
the end but it could be a totally unrealistic
number it doesn't matter what that number is it's
about how you got there can you tell us more about
how you wrote definition please yeah so I was in
a UCB sketch writing class in 2015 and every week
we had to write a new sketch so always coming up
with new different ideas and one of my sketches
was entitled spelling bee winners where are they
now which was based on my fourth grade spelling
bee experience and if you research spelling bee
winners they are all doing amazing things they are
working for NASA they are designing robots they
are winning the World Poker Tournaments and and
I just thought it would be funny if one of these
spelling bee winners grew up to be unsuccessful a
loser living in their mom's basement playing video
games just not doing much with her life so that
was that was the gist of my sketch and this was
four pages long and then I in at the end of 2016
I got into a Sundance screenwriting lab and
I went to the screenwriting lab and it was
really inspiring and amazing and in 2017 a
couple months later I decided to go to the
Sundance Film Festival for the first time and I
went as a Sundance influencer Sundance asked me
to take over their Instagram and their Twitter
and go to certain events and interview people
and it was actually a great way to experience
a first Sundance kind of within the Sundance
family and my friend Justin Chon's film [__]
was playing there and so I went to this premiere
of [__] and was just completely blown away by
the film and I cornered him at his post party
and I asked him how he got it made and he said I
just got money from my friends and family and we
just went out and made it ourselves and I was
like great that's what I'm gonna do so I went
back home after that first Sundance and started
jotting down ideas for definition please based on
that sketch that I had written two years prior
and then throughout 2017 I worked on the first
draft in 2018 I worked on subsequent drafts of the
film and a question I started with that premise of
okay what happens when a spelling bee winner
grows up to not fulfill her potential and I
took that question and I asked okay what what
would be the reasons why this would affect her
in in not taking a job somewhere in moving on
with her life and and I decided to answer those
questions by oh it's her relationships with
her family with her mom with her dad with her
brother and and her community in general and so I
Incorporated those aspects into my script and as
I believe at the end of 2018 I had my shooting
draft of my script and I was ready to either get
a production company on board to shoot it or shoot
it myself and you approached family and friends
so in terms of making the movie I had gone back to
Sundance in 2019 this time with HBO and Justin's
next film is purple was premiering there and I
got out of that screening and I was like Justin
has made two films in the time that I told him
that I was gonna make my film I am disappointing
myself with not getting out there and shooting
my film then and there I decided I'm gonna shoot
definition please in the summer of 2019. and so
this was January 2019. as soon as I decided I
got an email out of the blue saying that a show
that I had sold to a studio was caught up in the
merger in the Time Warner merger so they were now
releasing the rights back to me along with sending
me a gigantic check so I was like well this is a
sign because I had just decided to shoot my film
so I took that check and put it into definition
please and I was the first money into my film as
an investor and then I got back from Sundance and
I just went full force in raising money everyone
I talked to everyone I had coffee with everyone I
was hanging out with I would say hey can you put
money into my movie or do of anyone who would put
money into my film and so the thing with artists
and actors in La is they don't necessarily have a
ton of money to just be willy-nilly investing in
other people's films but they do have cousins and
they do have friends who are maybe necessarily not
in the industry so they want to dip their toes
into the industry and something that I noticed
was that since I had already put money into
my film it was easier to get other investors
on board and put money into the film and then
we just raised all the money and we were as
we were raising the money we were prepping to
shoot so we were getting our crew together we
were getting our cast together and I did not have
auditions for the cast I just texted my friends
who I knew would be right for the roles and a lot
of them luckily said yes and were down to come to
Greensburg to shoot my little film with me and
then we got to Greensburg and we shot the film
where did you put everyone up did they stay
at your parents house no no we actually got
an extra producer came in at the last minute and
we got this influx of money which was really great
and we got to put everyone up at a Hampton Inn
nearby and they all had a blast it was next to
his sheets I don't know if you're from familiar
with sheets in Western Pennsylvania but sheets
is an MTO sort of attached to a gas station but
they make these incredible sandwiches especially
breakfast sandwiches that I'm obsessed with
called schmiscuits schmuffin schmeagle's and
just these delicious Fresh Foods and the Hampton
Inn was walking distance from a sheet so a lot
of our cast and crew also got obsessed with sheets
like I am so that was really exciting but that but
what was also really amazing amazing about the
Hampton Inn was it was only about two or three
years old so it felt like a new hotel and they had
breakfast every morning and and I really believe
in taking care of cast and crew and it just makes
the overall atmosphere of the film just better
and if if the cast and crew are happy then you'll
have a good product and everyone will be working
well together and and I truly believe in that so
I was really excited to be able to put everyone up
in in a nice-ish hotel and give them rental cars
and oh wow and fly them out and and it was great
it's interesting because two of your your very
important projects all came with a found like
Newfound money like a check that showed up
that you weren't really expecting I just
find that interesting yeah and what like
sometimes when people get Newfound money
they spend it in different ways they'll put a
deposit on a house they'll take a trip they'll
decide to start a family or what have you and and
for me my priority has always been my work and
so I there is never any question of I'm going
to put this money back into my work obviously
I have a quote here I think from you I decided to
take it into my own hands and write the dream rule
I always wanted to play so I've been in Hollywood
for a while and I've auditioned for a lot of roles
and a lot of the roles that I was auditioning
for tended to be the the same type of roles so
they were very they were stereotypes they were
putting me in a box of these characters would be
going through an arranged marriage or they would
have strict parents or they would be pursuing a
career that they didn't necessarily want to pursue
but they were too afraid to do the other thing and
so I just noticed like a couple of those roles
I'm like oh okay this feels interesting this
feels like a new way of telling the story but then
it just kept happening that it was the same role
over and over and and I just I didn't really
understand it but then but then I understood
that Hollywood sees different ethnic groups
as monoliths and only sees this person in this
type of role as as a doctor or or a smart Tech
person and so for me I just wanted to be able to
play a role where where it was more nuanced and
maybe there are bits and pieces of that as as in
in definition please Monica does have a science
background which is somewhat of a stereotype
but I wanted to take that that that genius
stereotype and that science background and
Verge it into something new and that I
hadn't seen before and and I said okay
well she smokes weed and she hooks up with guys
and and she's pretty chill except in this one
family department and so it was exciting for
me to play and create a role that had so many
facets to it instead of this one thing and and
that's what I set out to do in terms of casting
the rules in my film a really fun story for me was
when I got a hold of Anna Kaja who plays Jaya the
mom in my film and she said yeah of course send
me the script and then I sent her the script and
she responded by saying I've played a lot of
South Asian moms she has played priyanka's
mom in Quantico she has played jamila's mom
on the good place she has played ritesh who
is plays a role of sunny in my film she
played his mom on his TV show stitchers
already so she had already played his mom before
and she said I've never seen this role before and
this is really exciting because the mom in my
movie has such a fun Arc and she said that it
was just going to be really fun to play that role
because she had never been offered something like
that before and and that was exciting for me to
hear because I wanted to not only write the role
for myself that I wanted to play but I wanted
to write other characters that my friends who
had maybe been offered certain types of roles in
the past that they would also be excited to come
in and be like oh I've never gotten to do this
before thank you for giving me this opportunity
and your brother has an ark too yes yeah
all the characters definitely wanted to
make sure that every single character has
has their own story in their own Journey
how do you feel about actors who refuse to write
roles for themselves create their own work so
they don't want to be put in a box they don't want
to have to play the same type of person over and
over again but then they're not willing to create
work that they actually want to watch I feel that
just don't have like the patience or the
discipline to sit down on a computer and
write their own roles but then I say you
got to go out and make writer friends
make these writer friends you got to make these
filmmaker friends these are director friends and
and get them excited about your story get them
excited about the roles that you want to play
and that you haven't seen so if you feel like
you can't do it yourself then surround yourself
with other creative people who maybe can do
that for you and in this day and age do you
think it's reasonable for people not to want to
create their own work because it's it's not about
sitting home waiting for someone to call anymore
so much of work is self-generated today I think
in this day and age you really do have to go out
and create your own work and there's no excuses
anymore like I said the iPhone 13 just came out
and if you've looked at the Cinematic mode of
that iPhone you can make an amazing short film
shot on the iPhone 13 and get sound equipment
from Amazon and just have it have really great
cinematic quality and have really great sound and
you don't even have to go that far there
are Tick Tock videos that I watch of
different people and their parents and their
grandparents that are just as exciting and even if
you don't feel like you can go as far as to make a
short film you can make little videos on Tick Tock
or YouTube or Instagram live and figure out what
works for you and maybe put videos up on Snapchat
and if that doesn't work for you then take another
path like I said it's all about taking risks it's
all about actually doing it so even if you
think oh I can't write this for myself then
make a friend go to these UCB sketch writing
classes go to these improv classes you'll make
friends in those classes that's what I've done and
then you continue to work with those people that
you really gel with and that's what's exciting so
find your community and I'll create work together
do you wish you had started writing earlier in
your career I started writing pretty young so I
started writing short stories and poems and songs
since I don't know second grade or something I was
always really into my books I was always really
into stories when I would go to the Indian parties
with my parents on the weekends graduations
birthdays and anniversaries and thanksgivings
I was always sitting in the corner reading my
book just into my stories and that inspired me
to write my own stories and so I've I've written
stories that I've transferred into scripts and
so I started writing very young and I
was always really good like I mentioned
I was really good at math and science
but all I was also good at English too
so that was part of it and I enjoyed writing it
gave me a break from the from the rigid structure
of math and science and and it was always a
stress reliever for me so really enjoyed writing
from a very young age so transferring it over to
screenwriting wasn't a hard thing to do for me
so when you would be going to those parties and
family barbecues whatever and you had the book
where people like put the book down come join us
what are you doing never never that that's not an
Indian thing to do okay oh she's studying reading
like babysitters club or Sweet Valley Twins
or Sweet Valley High I wouldn't necessarily be
studying but but in the Indian American Community
you don't really stop a kid from Reading okay ever
do you feel you have a choice to write direct and
act or it's a compulsion like you can't not do
it it's a compulsion and I think it goes back to
your first question of having a backup plan and
there's honestly I think there have been various
acting classes that I've been in out here and
they always say if there's anything else that
you want to be doing you need to go out and do
that instead of being in entertainment there's
honestly nothing else I would rather be doing
and I know that if I had stayed at that job at
Accenture I would be making billions and millions
of dollars at this point and been promoted and
that just wasn't it for me and it it's not about
the money and it's about waking up every day and
getting to live my dream and that's what keeps me
going and that's where the compulsion comes from
do you ever have friends that took that path and
there's nothing wrong with that path who say why I
secretly Envy you I love that you went out on your
own and you kind of forged your way and you didn't
worry about whether you had this title or that at
this point all the time lots of friends who went
a certain path that they were maybe supposedly
had to go down because of what their parents said
or just because of what a community says or what
society says in general what you can and cannot do
with your life what you have to be doing at the
age of 25 at the age of 27 at the age of 30 and
yeah there are a lot of friends that are envious
of what I'm doing and I'm just really happy
to be living the life that I'm living how many
characters have you actually created for yourself
multiple I've created so many characters
for myself and some of those characters
have probably never made it to the screen but
they're still on the page or they're still in
my mind and and it's exciting because none of
them are the same and they're all based on maybe
something small something real that has happened
to me an experience or a thought or an inspiration
but but all those characters are so different
and that's what's exciting because there are
so many roles that I've created for myself
that I'm excited to play very soon and to
imagine them visually on screen is is what I live
for what's one that you haven't created yet that
you want to play like it would really take
you out of your comfort zone or challenge you
I felt like my role in definition please was
pretty challenging that's one of the most dramatic
pieces that I've ever written it's definitely a
dramedy but but it it leans into that drama for
bits of the script and and I think going to those
vulnerable places as an actor I was just really
lucky to surround myself with amazing actors that
truly brought it and and made me a better actor
and so playing the role of Monica in definition
please was very challenging and very fulfilling on
its own and and and I believe that there are roles
percolating in my head that that I'm not aware
of that that will come out at some point and I'm
excited to face the challenge of those rules too
and I know you get asked this a lot but how much
of sujata was in that role not a lot not a lot I
think like I mentioned the the entire script was
based on me winning the my class spelling bee so
I obviously never won the National Spelling
Bee or else it would be googleable but that
definition please and that character was based
on a lot of different experiences and people
that I've come across in my life being around
a really large flourishing Indian American
community in Western Pennsylvania and then also
college and after college took little pieces of
of my life to create the fictional world of
definition please and so instead of a coming
home story it's a leaving home story because
the character has options she just chooses
her surroundings yes okay and I don't care maybe
I'm I don't know spoilers here but how come not
not a coming home story where you where you
decided to come home to the same situation but
you you had the career what was the difference
why did you why did you do the opposite I think
what was really exciting for me to explore with
Monica is the idea of a stunted growth the idea of
I've been successful I've had the peak of my life
what is ever going to be better than winning the
National Spelling Bee and those thoughts in your
head oh nothing's ever going to top that it's like
being the quarterback of the winning team senior
year of high school and then 20 years later you
are not really doing much and so that that kind of
story is exciting to me of like a stunted growth
of of how is this how is my life like and how can
I get out of it as opposed to a coming home story
I feel like I've seen that many times before
and and I wanted to explore something new in
terms of in terms of what you said a leaving home
story so reliving the glory of the desert because
some people high school was not their Glory time
yes and and that was actually an awful time and
they don't want to relive it but then there's
others that they do you're right they peek at a
certain age and I do I would imagine that would
be very difficult and and and then they don't
nothing sort of the magic never happens again yes
yes that's what's exciting to me that that story.